hey guys so this is a pretty requested
video it's the what is on your iPhone
kind of embarrassed some of the apps but
I didn't want to change anything because
I really wanted to be super realistic
and just show you guys what is really on
my iPhone I was scrolling through like I
don't even use half of these things feel
free to leave a video response with
whatever you guys have on your iPhone
it's a pretty high-tech shoot that I
have going on here I actually have one
camera here and one camera here so
you'll be able to see what I actually
have on the phone all right so we got a
calendar well dive into these folders
here's my Apple folder and this is my
camera folder Safari Facebook wrote me
Foursquare ways which is seriously the
best app for directions ever ever fancy
MyFitnessPal which I probably should use
a little more often path Pinterest
Instagram YouTube WordPress from a blog
turf pages foes zip boom and down here
usually my most important apps I have my
text messages my mail tweet bot and my
camera and if you notice there is no
phone on my main screen I hate talking
on the phone apple folder app store
settings clock reminders phone videos
iTunes maps photos
boom brothers stops contacts compass
voice memos calculator and passbook
don't use any of those inside this
folder is kind of my camera apps this is
Evernote food aviary which is a great
app camera plus also big fan Scanner Pro
don't think I've ever really use that
diptych after globe vent eke action
movie video strum I love strum okay next
page got the capture app and this is
Newton here it's more Apple apps that I
don't really use iTunes you books Find
My iPhone I actually use that quite a
lot find friends which I used to stock
my sister and Ryan so and then were you
guys are all the time music games Center
I'm of the cards speed test I like to
test how fast my internet is all the
time oh hi guys here's a continuation
because I started editing and guess what
I forgot to do all that's right tell me
what was on this page but since I
recorded this video I also downloaded
this new app called vine all you have to
do is film something touch the screen to
record move record something else and
look what it makes makes use sweet
little movie
and also is the unofficial hydrastine
app you guys want to download oh you can
see when I post new videos look at this
look at this it's unofficial it's not
official so it means it's not official
unofficial but it's officially pretty
sweet now on to the apps that I forgot
the YouTube capture app Amazon gems free
Yelp uber which is amazing for catching
a ride to the airport my 18 t so I can
pay my bill taxi magic stash Matic sash
Matic that says Equinox Chrome Kindle
pink pad that's for me and my lady
friends so we know when we have our
monthly visitor every month welcome to
my life test flight clone camera Google
Calendar echo graph and pear sana
elastic and can't say I've ever really
use that except once the App Store app
Xbox SmartGlass trip tracker unless my
boys Google Maps Monty blocks never
played that Angry Birds
I have played that on my iPad don't know
what that is supposed to also used to
post to my blog out my window and other
random social network I actually don't
like it's social tape don't remember
what that is do YouTube don't remember
what that is
clash of clans played that once kept
crashing heyday obviously didn't click
that candy crush with the heck this game
right here my Oreo is so fun twist lick
and dunk we twist lick and dunk or is I
know it's crazy how this was what I was
Christmas time I was trying to work on
planning gifts for people so this I got
the gift planner stupid
although Elster was pretty cool actually
used elf stir a lot for Christmas
so that was a kind of a cool thing sign
and send tada some other camera app and
I actually really liked it uh Bukka full
cloudy insta frame letter effects free
over this kind of what I look at I just
seen that's me that's my blog sesame
frequency holy crap I want to crap on
here Google mess bokeh cam effects low
me big lens micro can't never use that
actually near cam effects never use it
don't know buckle booth Flickr camera my
password so I don't even know figured
scan Facebook poke obviously never used
that some ecards classic StubHub
for all those concerts football games I
want to get snapchat doesn't work all
the Furby app in some place which is
pretty cool frame artist
Shazam green kitchen wallet Nike
you'll Bend for key wipe the GAT chase
message me and ha date yoga like
together to yoga so those are the apps
that I have on my iPhone I'm gonna say
probably my favorite apps that are most
used is obviously all the social
networking apps so Facebook Foursquare
these fancy a lot ways I use pretty much
all the time so that I'm able to get
from point A to point B in Los Angeles
and not get lost couple of my favorite
apps that have recently been using is
jib-boom my favorites and then using so
much these are my just creepy creepy oh
hey look this is me just telling you to
follow me on drift boom mwah
I'm verified now how's the love post big
post fan and post your outfits and you
say where they're from Yelp Yelp Yelp
you up y'all so that's what's on my
iPhone what's on your iPhone tell me
tell me now if you don't have an iPhone
what's on your whatever phone that you
do have oh no I have a spilled my drink
thanks for watching make sure you guys
subscribe so you'll see when I post new
videos I'll see you guys soon